Please join me in welcoming
Susan to go go over.
We're really delighted to have her.
Yeah,
that's great.
To be back.
Yesterday was so much fun and I see some
repeat basis people who brought their
partners.
So
it's my joy to do this work.
It's my joy to speak with parents about
perhaps the most important thing going
on in our lives. Yes, we care very
much about the world, the planet,
our careers,
our jobs.
But something happens to
us then we become a parent.
That's the changes as a
reference. I mean, I know for me,
um, when I became a
mother, actually I had a,
when I went into labor, I, I really didn't
know it was going to be that intense.
So after the second,
I think the second contraction,
I told my then husband,
um, I've changed my mind.
I don't want to do this actually.
And 27 hours later and nine
and a half pounds later,
I became a mother and
I'm,
I'm a different human being
in every possible way.
Not only because of the love that was
birthed in my heart,
but also because no one,
I don't know if this is your experience,
but nobody can push your
buttons or challenge you,
like your children. I'm
getting a lot of nods, lousy.
You know what I'm talking about
because not only are we really not
all that prepared for what it is to be
responsible for the unrelenting
demands of other people all the time,
but
also, you know, we're the same species.
We don't become a different
species when we become a parent.
So we're still getting tired,
overwhelmed.
We still have our baggage
from our own upbringing,
feeling overpowered or
invisible or whatever our
particular flavor of challenge
might've been as a child.
And so when we become a parent,
we have this opportunity to
grow our children, raise them,
but also to grow ourselves.
And that's one of the,
the gifts of this work. And one of the
reasons I have so much fun doing it.
I speak all over the world.
I've delivered the same
talk or as similar in,
in almost every continent.
And then I do as as or
Tico said a lot online.
We have a lot of programs.
I have a monthly membership where I've
got people from every country that meet
with me every month for you know,
not very many dollars a month.
We just talk about whatever's up for them.
So I'm working with parents now for
you to progressively to help them
internalize what we're
learning because the truth is
okay
the things I teach work really well.
In fact we were talking this morning
cause I did a three hour workshop here at
Google yesterday and then,
and I've also done some other talks in
the area of various organizations and
churches and schools and people
try something the next day.
And you were saying just this one little
adjustment avoided a meltdown with her
two and a half year old or maybe
two year old. Right. And, and how,
even though it isn't intuitive,
the things I'm going to teach you
today may not be how you were raised.
It's not rocket science.
It's not that difficult to begin doing
it in a parenting in a way that both
reassures our kids that there is a grownup
in the room, which is very comforting.
And that also
preserves the love and the connection.
A lot of us were good kids, right?
We cooperated, our parents
said do something, we did it,
but sometimes that came at a cost.
Sometimes we got sneaky and we just went
underground about the thing we wanted
to do that they were
preventing us from doing.
Or sometimes we just built up resentment
we did, or, or worse, maybe not worse,
but we would also,
when we were in trouble or struggling
with something and we needed a sane person
to sort out the tangle
moments of our life,
we would turn to our friends instead of
our parents who had life experience and
who, who. So you know, hopefully
cared about our best intent.
So my work is very much about holding a
place for our children that allows us to
parent them, guide them, support them.
Yeah.
Uh, and continue to build a very
deep and strong connection with them.
So I'm going to go over a few things
today and then we'll have some questions.
And let me start by giving you the,
the initial piece,
the fundamental piece of my work.
And that is that I believe that parents
need to be what I call the captain of
this ship for their children.
That means not that you're
in control of your children.
I am definitely not advocating control.
I'm about being in charge,
being the person that they can turn to.
If you're using this nautical theme
of captain of the ship, you know,
if you're on a ship and
you hear this alarm go off,
you don't want the captain leaping over
the side of the ship because he or she
doesn't know what to do or as overwhelmed.
You want the captain who's steady,
who's calm,
who's competent,
who can handle the news that there was
a leak or that there's a heavy storm
ahead and does it jump ship. I
guess that's the term, right?
And so the idea,
I'm going to demonstrate a very simple
hand motion for you so that you can
remember it. And lots of people telling
me that they, they and their partner,
we'll end up using these signals behind
the Tillman to that just to reinforce
and remind themselves of holding
this place for their children.
Even when our buttons are getting pushed.
My right hand's going to represent the
parents and my left hand will be the
child. Okay. Parent Child,
I have a watch on the child and if
that helps. So the child might say,
um, maybe your, your nine
year old says, Daddy,
I want to watch horror movies
from hell tonight at 11 o'clock.
And you say, Oh, well
I'm afraid not, you know,
because as the parent, as a captain,
that's not a good idea. You, you know,
you have a child who is very
impressionable. Images are very powerful.
This is a kid is not going to sleep for
the next six months if he watches horror
nights from hell. So you say, well, I'm
afraid not. And the child says, why not?
And you say, now watch this carefully
because you'll have that dream.
No, I won't. Yeah.
You watched a movie that wasn't nearly
that scary and you couldn't sleep for
days. I know, but that movie had man pyres
and the blood was oozing. This movie,
all my friends have seen it and there is
no vampire oozing blood in this movie.
Well honey, it's not about the oozing
blood. So who's in charge here?
You guys? No one. Nobody's in charge here.
So I called this the captain of the ship.
When you go here,
I call this the two lawyers,
the two lawyers.
This is where you're arguing.
You're each arguing for your position.
One is defending against guess the other
usually rational thought and arguments
to try and convince the other
person of why you're right.
Does that sound familiar to any of you?
Parents say,
oh, I lived there, but wait, there's a,
another evolves even further.
If you don't let me watch that movie.
I'm not doing my homework or I'm not
doing my chores or I'm not going to feed
the dog or I'm going to go be tease my
brother, you know, knocked down his tower.
And now you're down here
and you're,
you're feeling internally,
how are you feeling when
you're, when you're like that?
Like your child is attempting to put
you into the corner holding you hostage,
desperate, angry,
disrespected, out of control.
And from this place,
which I call the dictator,
because dictators don't have authentic
power. They have no genuine authority.
They ruled by fear and intimidation.
They can wipe out bank accounts through
your family and prison. Take your home,
confiscate your possessions.
So it looks, it's full power,
but they don't have any genuine power.
But from down here in the dictator mode,
you will bribe or threatened because
you feel overwhelmed and you feel out of
control. And in an attempt to feel
in control again. But remember,
this is not about control.
This has been in charge.
You will assert your way, but that
comes at a cost because your child,
now, as I said, there can be
resentment. There can be fear.
None of us like to be intimidated into
doing what we're being asked to do. Do we?
So captain of the ship to lawyers,
dictator,
everything that I teach and all these
Richard had talked about the summits and
the membership program and the
classes I do online classes,
everything is about this
because when we come
alongside our children, okay,
so this is my little hand motion rather
than at our children as the lawyer who
argued or as the dictator who threatened
when we come alongside them as that
confident happen,
life is so much easier.
They want to say yes, they want to
cooperate. They look to us for guidance,
they're receptive to our wisdom.
It's so much easier to parents.
So I want to do a quick demonstration.
Would you come up and have I prepared
you or anything? Okay. Nope. Nope.
So he's not been primed.
All I want you to do is face me right
there and if you put your hands out, okay.
Ready? Okay, great. Okay.
Thank you so much. Would they rather
have a pause or did I ask you to push?
No, no, but you pushed.
And I've done this in every part of
every part of the world.
Okay. And without exception,
everyone pushed it.
So it's not, I'm not. Yes, he shouldn't
have pushed. That's your instinct.
And the reason for this is that we push
against that which pushes against us.
That's how we're wired.
So when I began to push against him,
of course he was going to push back.
Now if you were in the martial arts field,
which some of you may be,
I suppose you know that you could just
move out of the way and let me fall
forward of my own momentum.
But we're not wired like that.
So when you come at your child
from lawyer mode or from dictator,
they are going to push back.
If you'd like to have power struggles
with your children, if that's your goal,
come at them.
Why didn't you start your homework?
Of course you can't go see that movie.
How many times have I told
you to brush your teeth?
All of those are push and you will
more often than not get pushed back.
And there is a better way. I mean, that's
the thing. If there was no other option,
then I would say, oh well we all
turned out all right, it's fine.
But since there's a way to parent our
children staying present, staying in, uh,
you know, you know, more receptive,
creating more receptivity.
I think it's worth exploring
not only because it's so,
it makes the climate in
our home or peaceful and
harmonious and happy and safe.
But here's a, here's the bonus. There's
a bonus to this. We get to heal.
Yeah,
we get to heal.
I know in the raising of my
son doing it differently,
certain things of course are similar
to the way my parents with me,
but some of these things
as I learned along the way,
and I certainly didn't know all this
when he was first around either I'm,
I'm a work in progress,
but so much healing has
happened for me internally.
Even beyond therapy.
Just that,
okay,
that this is what it feels like to,
to be,
be watch a child bloom,
watch a child feel they can shine and
be who they're supposed to be and have
their own point of view and
feelings. And you know, it's,
it's a learning process for sure,
but it's a glorious one.
So when we're captaining this ship,
things go better.
I want to give you some ideas
for how you can do just that.
The first piece that we know about what
motivates children to see us as that
cabin is connection and attachment.
So if I gave this example, remember, um,
let's say that you were part of a,
of a tribe.
And so in times past or in some
other part of the world even today,
and your child drifted or wandered over
to the edge of the perimeter of that
tribe's territory,
let's say it's your,
your four year old child and a stranger
approaches from the other side says,
Hey, you come with me. Huh? What
do you want your child to do?
Say No.
And who do you want them to run back to?
You? Right? This is a good thing.
Okay?
Children,
this is very important,
are wired to resist being bossed.
This last,
in case you hadn't noticed,
children are wired to
resist being bossed around.
The good news is because that would be
highly inconvenient for us as parents.
How do you ever get anything accomplished?
Do they want to brush your teeth? No.
Do they want to do their
homework? No. Do they want, right?
We can override that
instinct by attachment.
So the child runs back to you because
you're the one to whom he or she is
connected and we get,
that's the loophole for this.
Why is instinct that Mother Nature has
embedded in our children for survival?
We don't want them subject
to the influence of those
who might not have their
best interests at heart.
So it's good that they're wired to
resist being bossed around outside that
circle. That's safe influence. How do so?
So the way we override that, the way
we foster greater, greater receptivity,
greater cooperation begins with as
that captain developing attachment,
the way the roots of a
tree go wide and deep.
We s we develop a sturdy
foundation of connection.
So here's the tree,
everyone see the tree above the ground.
There's the tree and below
the tree are the roots.
This is the root system.
Now
the health of a tree is not really,
you can't really determine by looking
at what's going on above ground.
It's really based on what what's going
on in the ground underneath how wide and
how deep and sturdy those roots are.
So there are six stages of attachment
that a child moved through in their first
six years of life and then
continues to go through in life.
I used new felts model, which I think
is an excellent model in my courses in,
in what I teach because it very clearly
illustrates this beautiful journey of
bonding and connecting.
And if attachment is weak in
any or all of these areas,
you will see evidence of
that in the child's defiance.
It's not the only reason a child might
be chronically oppositionally defiant.
But if you have a child, when I get a
call for coaching or in our membership,
when somebody gets on,
you know, cause you know,
Tommy's just saying no to everything.
One of the first things I'll ask is
what's the quality of the attachment?
So when a baby is born,
the journey of attachment begins.
If you imagine the root just beginning
to enter the ground here, the first
movement into this process is proximity.
That's the first date I talk about
this in the books and then all my other
things. But if you taking
notes, it's proximity.
Proximity is the sound of your
voice. It's smell, it's touch.
It's very sense oriented because that's
where the infant is starting to connect
with you.
The second state is sameness.
So this is how two year old children
acquire language. They mimic you.
They want to be like
you. And if you have, um,
in one of my classes I had the
parent of a 16 year old who is very,
very drifting further and further away
toward her friends, away from mom.
And we started to look at where
they had similar interests.
And it was photography.
And so she,
she started to do photography with her
daughter sort of seriously pursuing it
and it reconnected them.
And this can be true across the board.
Even if you have a very young child,
they like ponies. They like,
I mean they like puppy men.
It is that you,
you look for a place where you have an
interest PR ideally that you share and
you build connection in that way.
The third stage,
so the roots are going even wider
and deeper is belonging or loyalty.
And this is the sense of the child
feels that you're on her side.
You know, we see issues
of this. For instance,
if you're the coach of your child's
soccer team and you're the coach,
and so from time to time you might have
to treat your child like all the other
children and you might have say, hey
dude, you know, you should have done this.
Sometimes kids don't do very well with
that because it compromises their feeling
of loyalty or dad or
mom having their back.
Three year old children in this state
of developing attachment may push their
sibling off of your
lap, my daddy, my mommy,
and they may also, um,
propose marriage to you.
I just never used so much fun.
Fourth stage roots going even wider and
deeper is significance and significance
is the sense that the child feels seen
and celebrated and cherished by you.
Just as they are not based on their
achievements or their accomplishments are
how good they make you look
as a parent or as a person.
It's the delight that you have in their
existence in your life and it's very,
very powerful for children
to feel cherished by you.
It helps them feel close to you.
The fifth stayed around the eighth.
The roots even going
wider and deeper is love.
It's this pure unadulterated transmission
of warmth and connection that your
child feels in your presence,
not just the words,
it's the way your face might light up
when they come into the room or they,
they call you on the phone.
I know when my son calls this days,
now they put five and 26 years old. And
if he walked in the house, it's like,
Ooh, just love him. And it's
not just the words, it's this.
I connect.
I,
I move into a place where I remember that
love I lined myself up with it doesn't
mean always. It doesn't mean I'm
a few of all the time, but, but I,
but there's something very
pure about that that is felt.
We feel it with anyone who we love.
And then the final stage,
if all has gone well with these
stages in the age of six onward,
is being known,
being known.
So this is the child who wants
to tell you their secrets,
doesn't want to hold back from you
feel say.
And we teach children by our reactions
because if we react to their news rather
than responding in ways that
make them feel ashamed or afraid,
then we teach them not to tell us
what's really going on in their lives.
Especially as life gets more complicated.
So if you want your 14 year old to
tell you when she's thinking about,
um,
drinking with her girlfriends on Friday
night cause they're all going to try it,
then you want to ideally make it possible
for your four year old when that child
is four to come to you.
When she's afraid of something
or someone's been mean
to her at school or maybe
she was mean to someone
and got in trouble,
you want to make it safe because you're
that captain who respond rather than
reacts out of your own,
her or need or story.
Does that make sense?
So we can fortify and build connection
with their children all through their
lives. Proximity means you me,
let's play a game of chess,
right?
I seek out the child when they're not
chasing me or hanging onto my leg.
Please, one more game. Get any of that.
But you initiate out of a
generosity once in a while.
Go find your child when you're not
expecting it or demanding and say, hey,
I just had this great idea.
Do you want to go color and
your coloring but together?
And they haven't even asked
for it. Wow, that's amazing.
Sameness for something the two
of you enjoy doing and do it.
Take a cooking class,
go,
go study the bugs in the backyard if
you have at least some interest in new
child's fascinated,
belonging and loyalty.
If they have a homework assignment, rub
their shoulders, making a cup of tea,
be on their side,
let them feel that you're on their team.
And I've talked about significance
and love and being known.
So these are very fundamental
elements of my work that when we
change what I call the Ph of
our relationship with our child.
So imagine there's a cylinder
with a solution in it. And
it's funny, I'm a Google,
I have zero background is science.
So I'm going to sound
like a no more than I do.
This is like the one thing I kind of know.
So if you had a solution
that was too acidic,
the Ph of that solution
is to has too much acid.
You don't neutralize it by removing acid.
You add alcohol and you add base.
If I get a call or I,
I'm working with a family where the child
is chronically resistant or defiant.
One of my first questions will be
how would your child rate that?
The level of attachment on these six
areas in India in or the overview.
Because typically a child who feels very
close to you and connected tries their
best to behave for you.
They want to please you just like you do.
Okay.
You try harder for someone
that you genuinely like who
you feel genuinely likes
and enjoys you then then
out of obligation or duty,
it's just how we are.
So these stages of attachments,
while simple are so fundamental to being
the captain of the ship because they
change the Ph of that relationship.
So it's healthy.
See if something kind of to work with.
Does that make sense so far?
So far so good.
Okay.
There's a second piece that
goes into being that captain,
I won't go into this two months.
This is a, uh, a deeper topic,
but I want to just touch on it.
So imagine that you're holding a snapshot.
I always think of Polaroids, and I'll
bet many of you, if not Missouri,
don't even know anymore what a
Polaroid picture. But in my day,
which wasn't that long ago,
there were these cool cameras and you
could instantly take a picture and print
it. So I always picked it, the
Polaroid. So here's a Polaroid,
and this picture that you're
holding is of your ideal child.
Okay?
This is a child who when
you say, um, sweetheart,
it's time to start your homework. They
say, sure mom, thanks for reminding me.
And this is the tiled.
When you say, honey,
it's time to brush your teeth and
get new Jeremy's, you'd go, oh great.
I'm just so ready for that.
Good night.
Have a good night, mommy. I know you're
so tired. You get a good sleep. Now
this is your snapshot child.
I call it Snapshot Child Syndrome.
How many of you suffer from
snapshot childs and no.
And the reason that we move into lawyer
mode or dictator mode is that we lose
our cool
happens to the best of us.
And,
and so I'm always interested in
getting to the root of things.
Like I'm not a bandaid person. I'm not
a person that's scripts for you. What?
Here's what to say when your
children are fighting the backseat.
Here's what to say. When you found
out your daughter was teasing,
I want to know why. Why does some,
why does that behavior makes sense?
So the root of this issue of why we lose
our cool and move into that argument of
lawyer where we're pushing
or that dictator who is
overpowering and intimidating
to feel some sense of flow control is,
is not because our child's
kicked down his brother's tower.
It's because we think he shouldn't have.
Yeah.
It's the mismatch between this photo of
our idealized child and that real one in
flesh and blood in front of us.
That mismatch causes us to lose our cool.
Does that make sense?
It's an inside job.
It's what we're believing in our
head that contradicts reality.
Richard can mentioned Byron Katie,
and I don't know if any of you familiar,
but I love the work of Byron Katie and
I've been doing some parenting programs
with her and it's been set to the light
because she has a process of inquiry
that I include in my books and in my
classes. We don't do it right now,
but that gets you to look at the stories
that you're telling and believing that
caused you to create stress and distance
and difficulty in your life and in your
relationship.
So staying captain means that we
have to throw the snapshot away.
Okay,
this is the child you have
for better or worse,
maybe it's not what you expected.
I think for most of us,
not all of us, if we're really
allowing our child to be who they are,
there's going to be some variation
between the imagination that we had,
who they might be and their personality.
Maybe you have a child who's,
I've had sessions with
people on the phone who,
who end up sobbing within
10 minutes because, uh,
this person is a very gentle,
was very passive, was as a,
as a little girl, not allowed to really
be very assertive or express herself.
And she's got this intensely
fiery five-year-old, no,
I'm not going to do that.
And, and boy, you know, mom
just bumps up against that.
Now on the one side where we've gotten
to in our work is what a gift this
daughter is revealing to her.
How she can locate within
herself her own strength,
her own will to some degree,
maybe not clumsy and intense
way that her child is.
Sometimes you're a very intense person
and you really are competitive and you
love sports and you get this very gentle,
sensitive, a little child, not like you.
So it's when we are stuck on holding
this image up against the real child that
we our cool and we try and argue them
into or intimidate them into being
different than the off.
So that's a side piece that helps us
be the captain looking at what we're
believing our child should be looking
at the story that we're telling in our
head of how they should feel. He
shouldn't knock down the tower, the tower.
Is it true?
What are three reasons why you're a
little boy should have knocked down to his
brother's tower?
And I know that don't take that literally.
I'm not suggesting he
should have knocked it down,
but if we look at that question,
why does this behavior make sense,
then I'll bet we could find white.
That was an obvious outcome of what
had happened up in the moments or hours
leading up to that.
That make any sense to you.
We look at the snapshot,
we throw it away and we,
we meet the child where they are.
The third piece that's so important, and
I want to make sure I cover this today,
is about coming alongside our
children rather than coming at them.
So I talk about um,
how when a child is frustrated,
it's like they're on this road
of frustration. Here's the road.
It's called frustration.
Okay?
Children are on this road many,
many times a day.
They can't have the cookie that they want.
They have to go to school and
they'd rather stay home with you.
They don't want to go to bed,
they don't want to brush their teeth.
They don't like you holding
their little buck brother.
All kinds of things happen where
children are frustrated. So the goal of,
of our parenting life is not about
preventing them from ever being pressed,
waited far from it.
In fact,
my position is that it's very important
for children to discover they can
survive and live through frustration.
Why?
How else are they going
to develop resilience?
Children become resilient because they
know they can survive something difficult.
So our job is not to fix everything for
them or move the universe over to where
they would prefer that it be,
but it's to be that loving,
compassionate,
present captain through the storm.
So the child on this road of frustration,
and there's only two ways this
can go if they go this way,
in that direction,
they come to a fork in the road.
So there's only when they come
to the fore, if they go this way,
they become aggressive. I
hate to, you're so mean.
Maybe they take it out on their sibling
or on the family dog or they they hate,
I hate myself,
we see that.
But if they come to the fork in the road
of frustration and they go this way,
the end of that little path is adaptation,
acceptance that you've come to
terms with life as it is. However,
however it's a process that
you can help them with.
So I've borrowed from the work of
Elizabeth Kubler Ross in death and dying
because the way I see it,
frustration in a way is like loss.
It may be loss of autonomy or freedom
of choice and maybe loss of you if they
have to go to school,
maybe loss of a really good cookie.
And so I work with this model of
grief because in a way it's a,
it's a small condensed grieving
process to get through that loss.
So who has an example of the
similar, want to share an, uh,
an example of a time when a
child has made a complaint?
Hmm.
Actually just happened yesterday.
My 12 year old came home from school
with a big sad oh attitude and went
straight to his bed. And it
was very unlike him because
normally he's very happy,
positive. And I went to him and I
said, what is the problem? And he said,
I can't believe it.
Somebody slashed my backpack while I
left it outside the bathroom. Yeah, yeah.
Why would they do that?
And I was, you know,
I could totally understand where he's
coming from because he felt like he was
yes. And in that process, that's unsafe.
So sorry to hear that
in that process really,
I already can watch you and get a sense
that you just joined them where he was.
And so that's a great example of her
getting to the end of this process,
which is feeling sad. So I,
if it's all right with you,
I'm going to invent a another version
just because you already did it. Okay.
So let's say that your
child complains that, um,
he never,
he doesn't get to watch more TV and
he really wants to watch this one more
program. Okay. That
anybody relate to that?
Just this one more program.
Does anyone want to play this out with me?
All right, I'll just do it. So
we have, we have a shot. Yep.
And also we're on camera.
So the child says to you,
mom, Dad, I just want
to watch one more show.
This is a really important episode
and we'll pretend there aren't
dvrs and all that. Okay.
For the purposes of this demonstration.
So the child, when you say,
I'm afraid now this time to start
your homework or get ready for dinner,
first goes into the, on the, on the road
to acceptance, first steps into denial
because
maybe he or she,
he has reason to believe that you
may change your mind based on prior
experiences.
If I rally hard enough,
maybe I'll get to watch this show. So come
on please. I just want to watch a show.
So the child's birth and denial.
If you still say no,
then we're in anger. You're so
mean. You never let me do anything.
You're, you're so strict. But Jacob's
parents let him do what I mean,
he gets to watch like five
of these episodes. You're
so strict. So there's anger.
You are [inaudible] park. Okay, next,
if we don't engage on that level,
we have bargaining.
Please.
If you just let me watch this one episode,
I promise I'll never ask for anything
again for the rest of my life.
He said, only thing I want. I promise you,
if you just let me watch this show,
I'll never ask for anything.
I'll do all my chores. I'll feed
the dog aisle, massage your feet,
whatever it is.
Okay?
Now if that doesn't yield the
desired outcome, we'll move on.
But it's not so easy because those
are invitations to go into lawyer and
dictator mode, right?
So your child denial,
you know he's going to just push and push.
Then anger,
you might counter the anger with
threats or anger of your own.
If he moves into bargaining, you
may go into lawyer mode. We'll know,
because I know that's not true.
You've promised many times before.
That's the only thing you wanted,
and then 10 minutes later you
wanted something else. Well,
that was different because it says your
child, because that was when you know,
I mean, listen, you're going
nowhere fast. If you go there,
these first three stages where
there's conflict intention,
I call it the Dab denial,
anger bargaining.
So the model is Dab, Duh.
So the first three stages,
the DAB,
we perpetuate.
We've prolonged the misery by arguing
why threatening all those things.
The fourth stage,
which is where
the shift actually can happen,
this is what you were talking about
with your son is disappointment now and
Kubler Ross's model. It was
depression. It's the disappointment.
It's inhabiting
your sadness.
It slamming against the truth that I
am not going to have what I wanted.
I have to let go for your son.
It was the truth and the sad truth
that somebody was so unkind who he has
contact with for the child who
wants to watch another show.
It's the realization of
the futility of his effort.
He is not going to get to watch that show.
So there's some children they need to cry.
Some kids just feel it,
a sinking feeling.
And if you can hold the captain
plays without being tempted to,
but it's only rare,
I'm good or which is what we do.
But you've gotten so many
thing you don't appreciate.
If you'd appreciate me more and all the
hard work I do and the organic food I
buy, then I would, I
might feel differently.
But if we stay clean
as that captain,
then the child magically moves through
this process through the final step,
which is acceptance.
They make peace with life as it is.
They come to terms with it
and we have not fractured or
compromise the relationship.
Does that make sense? This is not
easy because when we have a child,
every bone in her body
wants them to be happy.
So if a child is unhappy or complaining,
a lot of times we go down here because
we feel a desperate need for them to like
us or to feel happy again.
So we,
we changed the world to suit
them because they don't,
we don't like witnessing
them being unhappy.
And I'm not saying you never change your
mind, by the way. Here's the back door,
let's say that you're super tired.
Okay.
If you'd like, like, uh,
an out a loophole for the,
let's say you're really tired
and your tradition is that you,
um,
read to bedtime stories at
night and you've read your
two stories and your tiles
like,
oh,
I have a third story and they haven't
yet lost their mind or they're not being
awful. They just would really like
another story. And in your mind,
you kind of weigh the pros and cons.
Do I want to do this thing that
Susan's default one was talking about
or do I just want to get this over with?
So what I remember,
I just want you to be the captain.
So if they're being reasonable and you,
you know,
you think it might be quicker and easier
just to read the other, an extra story.
You know what you get to say, oh
my gosh, you must be a mind reader.
I was about to suggest we read
another story that's amazing.
Or you know, they want the
other cookie. How did you,
how did you know I was about to ask
you if you wanted another? Okay,
so you make it your idea
and you still hold that place not loving.
So I know that we have just a few minutes
and I want to take some questions,
but I wanted to sort of tie this up with
the last piece that goes into being the
captain. Just briefly. When
we come at our children,
you can't watch that show. It's
a scary movie. You're too young.
What do we get from them?
Pushback and resistance, right?
We can move into that anger
when we come alongside them with
what I call act one parenting.
Then we help the child feel understood,
validated,
and they soften and there's uh, uh, uh,
the guard comes down,
the walls come down.
There's a receptivity and we use act
one with the one I just taught you with
helping the child feel sadness.
So here's an example. Um,
the says,
I,
I hate my school and I never want to go
back to that stupid school. I hate it.
They come home from school
and say that to you.
Most of us do what I
call act to parenting.
We appeal to the towels left logical,
rational language based brain.
Okay.
Even though when they're upset,
they don't have one of those.
And I know I'm oversimplifying,
but Dan Siegel reassured me a couple of
weeks ago that I can still talk about
the rain. It's having these different
points of, so I'm comforted by that.
So we appeal to them with rational,
logical arguments to talk
them out of their position.
Does that work? No. Not
when they're already upset.
Because when they're upset, they're over
here in their feeling emotional brain.
That's where we need to join them.
We do that with what I call
act one parenting act one
parenting allows the child
to be where he is,
stays the captain.
We stay the captain.
We are already,
most of us say way too many words and I'm
convinced kids tune us out after about
seven.
And we,
um,
acknowledged briefly, I call it
comics. We're going to be like, oh hmm.
Shit.
Why? How? Fam Go boom. Okay.
So we're minimalists
when it comes to words,
but we're in passing and most important,
and this is a little formulaic, we,
we look to help the child,
not his head or say yes at least
three times so that it diffuses,
wow.
You're actually hearing me not like
you're angry because I would never presume
to decide I know what
someone else's feelings.
So please don't attribute that approach
to me cause I don't believe it's our
rights and decide how someone is
feeling and announced it as if we know.
But we could say it sounds like I get
the feeling that it seems as though,
so let me demonstrate this and then
I'd love to take some questions.
Is there anyone brave who has an issue,
a child who's complained about something
and they want to play this out with me?
All right, so you're my, how old are you?
How do you want to be you to eight year
old? Okay. So you're my eight year old.
And what's your complaint?
First I'm going to demonstrate act two
which is why they don't want you to do,
but you will probably intuitively do.
Cause that's how we were.
Most of us were raised. Okay, what's
your complaint you spend here?
You spend all the time with my little
brother and you don't spend any time with
me. Can you stand here? So like,
yeah, that's ridiculous honey.
I'm knocking on her left with, that's
your left, right? I'm knocking on her.
That's ridiculous.
Ice.
I played my little pony with you for like
two hours yesterday and was wanting my
attention.
But today you didn't spend any time today
because we had to go to the doctor's
office and I had to take, but I'm
right here with you and here mommy.
Okay, so how does this
feeling? Very disconnected.
I'm arguing. I'm validating, right?
So can you all relate to that?
There's almost an urgency
that we feel like,
let me just quickly
talk you off the ledge.
Let me quickly talk you
out of what you're feeling.
And I seem to believe or whatever reason,
largely how we were raised,
that the quickest route to that is to
convince your left logical brain to think
differently. It just
doesn't work. By the way,
I've done this same program for
businesses and employee relationships and
couples. I mean, this is not just
confined to the parent child relationship,
this dynamic. But we know that
that didn't, I didn't go over did.
Did you all relate? Okay, so
now I'm going to model act one.
You may see me in this act
one demonstration guiding
her to some sadness through
that Dab. Okay Betty. So
make the same complaint.
You always spend time with my little
brother, but no time with me mommy.
So now in my mind I might be thinking that
is so far from the truth that his own.
So it seems like you feel shortchanged
and like your brother has been
getting more time than yes.
And I wonder,
you kind of miss me.
I do,
yeah.
I'm so glad you told me.
Yeah,
of course. It's not always that tidy and
simple, but how was that for you? Oh,
that was more connected and that you care.
Yeah.
I'm not arguing her out of her position
now. There's so many ways this could go.
It might be that I find out that it's
not really sadly about me at all and my
fabulousness,
but really that her friends left her
to eat by herself at lunch. Right.
If I,
if I make room for her to feel
express herself safely and tell me,
is there more to that? I mean, is there
more about that you want me to know?
Okay.
Yeah. If you'd really aloone these
days because there's no friends
at school right now in my
lap. Right. I'm thinking,
I picked her up and saw her playing
with seven people on the playground.
So the temptation is very great to say,
what are you talking about?
The typical thing would be, but I saw you
with, you know, vivid edit at an event
and instead I joined her where she is.
So it feels like you're just on
your own a lot. Huh? Friends?
Hmm.
That doesn't sound fun
there anything that you think you
want me to help you with about that?
I'd like to have a play
date with Ella.
I wonder if we could set that up.
So there's, there's a possible,
I've empowered her to be a participant
in solving it. Thank you. Thank you.
That's good. It may also be that, um,
that it,
she just has to cry that maybe she's going
through a rough patch with all of her
friends. It may be not that
this would be for your child,
that she's not being a very nice
friend and she's been very bossy,
are very controlling of the other kids.
And so she's getting honest feedback.
But I want to know that because I'm the
captain and there may be a leak in the
whole of my ship and if I make everything
glossed over and perfect and I only
want to hear the good stuff, I
really can't effectively. Yeah.
So, um, all these things are,
are interplaying with each
other to be that loving,
present captain of the
ship and in the process,
this is what I said at the beginning.
We get to heal our
unfinished business at looms.
It's angry face.
Sometimes when we feel disrespected
or overwhelmed or confused or sad,
or maybe I was that child who had no
friends and now I'm going to jump through
hoops to make sure that by Gosh,
every child on that playground
plays with my daughter.
So I didn't have to re activate my
own pain of loneliness as a child,
not a healthy way to go.
I worked through my own material.
I support my child with the resources
that she has. She's a different person.
So it's a pretty magnificent
process. And I, as I said, just feel
overjoyed to have landed in what feels
like the work I'm supposed to do and have
met so many amazing parents
around the world. Um,
even the online community. I have a
Facebook group and I have a, Oh yeah.
That's to say I have this newsletter
who said, I was going to say this.
If you'd like to stay in touch with the
work I'm doing, please send the news, uh,
a text message.
I'll just give you this phone number
with the word newsletter in it.
It's 310-NINE-058Y-16TY-5
310-NINE-058Y-16TY-5 and
you can be part of our
movement, our tribe. We're doing
so many interesting things.
The next program coming up is on
coparenting liver narcissist and very,
very interesting with a woman
who wrote, uh, she's uh, uh,
highly respected expert in the field
when have a Harry called disarming the
nicest since.
But we do all kinds of parenting programs
online so that we can reach people
remotely. This is, we're doing today.
So who has a question that they get out?
Uh, so we have a, you want a kid
when you were in four months.
And so do you have any tips for how to
communicate with kids who don't talk yet?
Sure.
So you have a one year old,
so it's pre-verbal.
So some of the things I'm talking
aren't quite relevant to you yet.
They will be if you blink about five
times, that's how fast it take this.
So it's great that you're learning now.
In fact,
I want to do more work with expectant
parents because they have more time to
actually start learning new approaches
and then they can be more prepared.
Um,
with a young child,
a lot of the work I do tends to do
with you so that as you start to feel
overwhelmed or stuffed folks
getting triggered for you,
you have the resources to kind of
look at your own side of the equation.
And then with a toddler
you'll be doing a micro,
like a very simplified version of
some of this. Like I love Harvey Karp,
who talks about, um, um,
when it toddler really want something
that you don't get real wordy, you,
you go match about 30% of the
effect you want, you want,
you want to go outside so you can
meet your child on a very primal,
simple level. Even though the verbal
processing may not be what you, you know,
they may not be able to perfectly
translate, they'll get the feeling.
And so you acknowledged them
in that way and um, and,
and prepare yourself for what's to come.
What are the things that happens in
our house sometimes is they'll ask for,
you know,
one of my two daughters will ask for
something like another dessert or more
screen time or something like that and
we'll say no, and then they'll say why.
Which is I think a real invitation
to go into a lawyer mode there. Um,
so what do you think is a, you know,
some good approaches to handle it?
I love the question.
A lot of times when you have established
that something is not an option,
the child will say, why? And I want
you to get this. It's code for,
I really want it.
It's not why you're just getting confused.
Because we think that the
word part of the towels,
the message is actually their message.
That is not the case.
When a child is feeling a lot of feelings,
there's this glossy wrapping paper that
they wrap around the emotional content
of what's going on for them and they
deliver this gauzy wrapping wrapped up
thing of feeling and the Gazi wrapping
papers, the word part of the message,
it is not the message. And so
there will be times, however,
when your child is calm, respectful
and says, I really want to know why,
and you can say, are you sure? Do you want
to know why you can't have the dessert?
Or is this your way of saying, I really
want the dessert? I would just ask her,
get it clear. I'm not
sure if you're saying, uh,
that you genuinely want my rational
reasons or if this is just another version
of I so desperately want that
dessert, tell me what it is. Now.
I will also point out that in my work,
I don't suggest that you keep saying,
I know you really want the
dessert but you can't have it.
I know it's really good,
but I told you, you know,
I know you really want more deserved,
but in our house you only get one if you
keep reiterating the no. First of all,
it's like salt in the wound.
It's kind of mean,
but it also disempowers you
because if you know what,
and this is why many parenting issues,
when I do work with my members,
a lot of it is just helping parents
become more clear in the size. It,
when you're clear,
you have an aroma and
that's the captain thing.
And um, and so then you may
need to get super clear,
but once you're clear, don't keep saying
no, you can't, but here's why. But no,
you said at once it's already
established in your house.
I wouldn't even touch it.
I know you really want the dessert.
I know it doesn't seem fair.
Not, I know it doesn't seem fair,
but we don't have second desserts in
our house. Does that make sense to you?
Am I saying that?
Okay.
So, um, my nine year old daughter,
she's really addictive to a
Nintendo counselor games. So,
um, so when she's not
playing, she's, you know,
trying to get onto youtube to watch
other people playing all the time. So,
so I'm thinking about maybe
I ship because myself,
I have no interest in
gamma at all. So, so I'm,
I'm thinking about maybe I should
consider playing with her or to be more
attached with her in
terms of this interest.
Do you think that's a good way to yeah,
really interesting question.
I just did a this year,
it's still on it Susan stifelman.com
you can still get that,
a wonderful series on parenting
in the digital age and um,
it's a huge topic for me that I've been
writing and thinking and teaching about.
And that question is,
is a tangled one.
I would prefer that you find an interest
that doesn't involve parallel looking
at a screen, more contact, more
real life, really engagement.
That's what I would prefer. No, I'm not
saying this is an altar for your daughter.
There are children,
for instance on the spectrum,
some degree of autism or Asperger's
where that is a very effective way and
perhaps the easiest way to connect.
And there are children who
are depressed and again,
this is not your daughter, but I
have, when I've done my classes,
when we start to work with helping kids
sort of wean off or limited amounts of
time on the screen,
it's often a mask or cover up
for anxiety and depression.
And I would,
I would want to rule that out that she
is able to function and enjoy the world
because otherwise it's just
covering up another issue,
which sadly is true for many
children. Um, many kids,
that's the only time they
feel good or relaxed or c.
And then finally, um, you know,
it's a process and you would need
to be about what the limits are.
But I guess my short, shorter, coming
back to the original answer would be,
I wouldn't mind her teaching you a little
bit about the game as an entry point,
but I guess I would prefer that you think
outside the box with something really
interesting navy as an off suit,
maybe drawing and to characters or
building them out of something that's a
little more three d
actually,
she did try to teach me,
but I guess I did not
meet her expenditure. Oh,
well that's good information.
It's not you're right
thing and you can be very honest
with her and say, here's the truth.
I love authenticity with our kids. They,
they love the truth and they smell it.
Anyway, sweetheart, I'm wanting
to connect with you more.
I was thinking maybe I
would try and intend to,
but clearly it's just not my in
my wheelhouse. So here let's,
here's a big pad of paper.
Let's just together, right?
All the things we love doing and see where
there's some overlap and make that an
activity,
a bonding activity to do with her,
to come up with ideas of other
things that you could do.
It could be digging holes in the backyard.
I don't care whether it is,
could be a worm farm.
Okay. I guess that's it.
We need to wrap up.
Thank you all for tuning in and listening,
and thank you so much for
Chico for hosting this event,
and I look forward to staying in touch.
Yeah,
thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Susan.